[Music]
when will the record boom in corporate
deal-making that began over five years
ago come to an end it's a question that
deal makers who make millions advising
on transactions don't like to ponder too
often since 2014 more than 20 trillion
dollars worth of deals have been reached
in over 250,000 transactions there are a
few big-picture reasons why deal-making
has thrive low interest rates make for
cheaper borrowing rising stock prices
that allow for equity to be used in
deals economic growth that hasn't
necessarily translated into earnings
growth and most importantly the stable
geopolitical backdrop
those are the conditions under which
corporate executives tend to feel the
most confident about buying or merging
with another company that is why you
always hear dealmakers talking about
boardroom confidence as a leading
indicator of M&A activity the gains over
the past years have survived unexpected
geopolitical events that includes
Britain's vote to exit the European
Union in 2016 and later the election of
Donald Trump to President of the United
States each has affected M&A in its own
way the prospect of brexit has forced
the UK companies to prepare for the
economic impact of Britain's potential
withdrawal from the EU the boom in
outbound Chinese deal-making which took
place in the first stretch of the M&A
wave has come crashing down with Donald
Trump's trade war against China China
has responded by combining state-owned
companies to create national champions
of the future but despite a few
short-lived slowdowns in activity the
blockbuster deals
keep coming that is particularly the
case in the US which unlike Europe keeps
pumping out mega deals one thing that
could bring this deal party to an end is
a recession this would have a big
negative impact on transactions after
all stability is probably the most
important ingredient for deal-making
think about it this way nobody wants to
buy at the top of the market just before
valuations collapse